the world of Fire Emblem fates is full
of adventure and danger intrigue and
betrayal love and loss the opportunity
for glorious victory and the potential
for confusion but we're here to clear
that right up
hey everyone I'm ash Paulson from
GameXplain and I'm Chris waters from
GameSpot welcome to inside Fire Emblem
fates a two-part video series sponsored
by Nintendo in which Ash and I take you
through this tactical RPG and break it
down
we've got strategies we've got story
insights we've got paparazzi videos of
the royal family and we've got the
lowdown on the two different versions of
the game birthright and conquest all
delivered with minimal spoilers so you
can enjoy the story for yourself so
let's lay the foundation regardless of
which version you play the first six
chapters tell the same tale you are a
prince or a princess of noir a royal of
your own creation you have some mild -
serious amnesia about your childhood but
you do know who your siblings are Elise
Zander Camilla and Leo may have their
eccentricities but they love you which
is sweet standing in stark contrast to
your father King Garon who is a total
psycho
he's just rough the dude is evil and
it's pretty clear from these early
chapters that he's just trying to set
you up I mean just look at the sword he
gives you what Purple's the color of
royalty evil anyway after an early
mission goes wrong you end up in the
custody of the hoshi dinar me the sworn
enemies of noir they inform me that you
were actually born to the ocean and
royal family and abducted by noir when
you were a kid
Queen Mikoto is your real mom in Rio
mahine oka Sakura and Takumi are your
real siblings two households both alike
in dignity in fair Fire Emblem where we
lay our scene from ancient Grudge break
to new mutiny where civil blood makes
civil hands unclean you're talking about
the attack by nor on the innocence of
hoshido yeah yeah that was bad from
there the pads of Fire Emblem fates
diverge in birthright you stay with the
hoshi Don's your birth family and strive
to topple the norian Empire in conquest
he returned to noir to join the only
family you ever knew endeavoring to
change the Kingdom from within I think
the choice is clear
totally if the current price wait wait
what it is birth Christ you're you're
serious
you'd really just abandon your family
like that
God can't even sit next to this guy you
would side with the evil empire who just
murdered a bunch of civilians in cold
blood
unbelievable all right here's the thing
birthright is the place to start not
just because it's obviously the right
choice family Manor but because it eases
you into the game as battle mechanics
with simpler scenarios and medics that
can heal from a few spaces away
birthright introduces you to fire
emblems treacherous universe without
taking the training wheels off at least
we agree on that conquest is a harder
road to bringing about peace yeah that's
what noir wants higher level enemies
with damaging skills come at you early
and often so you need to be ready for
the challenge you're only as tough as
the soldiers by your side and as
birthright begins in earnest you get to
know your long-lost hoshii ten siblings
the soft-spoken socrata and the
tenacious yet tender area are more
complex an initial impression suggests
and getting to know your new old family
is a delight and you've got friends to
your childhood bro Silas joins your
cause early on after a brief
misunderstanding so I suppose not all
Noreen's are bad meanwhile on the
conquest path you are essentially sent
on suicide missions by your father King
Garon fortunately your siblings have
your back at least the bubbly
curly-haired healer joins you and brings
along her buff retainers Effie and
Arthur and Silas tags along here too so
you're never deprived of his dope
hairstyle and as your army grows so too
do your relationships romantic platonic
or antagonistic relationships are key in
Fire Emblem fates and one of the main
elements that makes the birthright and
conquest campaign so different I mean
come on birthright lets you fight
alongside allies like the super cool
ninja brothers kaze and sighs OH
compare that to a creeper like Camila
and conquest well let's just say
everyone knows that ninjas beat all oh
so you want to tell me that hiding in
bushes and chucking things at people is
cooler than flying on a freakin wyvern
slinging axes and raining down magic
from the freakin sky yeah man
I'll take living in the shadows and
raining down silent efficient death from
who knows where especially when facing
off against some of the sinister
characters that fly the nori and flag
it's nice to have some colorful villains
like Leo and a Zola to square off
against but staring down the business
end of an Orion weapon is not where you
want to be trust me well
fighting Honoka is Pegasus Posse in the
mountaintop sanctuary was no picnic
either but even though you vanquish her
you don't actually kill her and this is
a theme throughout conquest you
regularly command the more enthusiastic
try psychotic soldiers in your army to
leave defeated enemies alive the legacy
of noir is one of senseless murder but
you're trying to lead them in a new
direction oh sure and I suppose Knorr
brainwashing of top of me in Chapter ten
is also part of that new direction you
know talk to me did have a strange
moment during the maritime face off with
him in chapter 10 of conquest but I have
no idea what that was all about must be
a mystery for shadowed by both
birthright and conquest a mystery that
will leave you to unravel on your own
along with all the other intrigues and
revelations of Fire Emblem fates in our
next episode we're talking tactics how
to level up quickly how to optimize your
army strength how to keep the allies you
care about alive how to use the
battlefield to your advantage and how to
hit for maximum damage all that and more
on the next episode of inside Fire
Emblem fates for the glory of Lord
emotional
you